hello my name is dan hertz i'm an
assistant professor at the university of
michigan college of pharmacy
thank you for attending my talk today on
pre-treatment dpyd testing
to prevent severe fluoropyrimidine
toxicity
so just as a quick background there are
two drugs in the fluoropyrimidine class
the first is an iv agent called
5-fluorouracil
and the second is an oral pro-drug
called cape cytobean
these drugs are commonly used in several
different solid tumors as i have listed
there
like most chemotherapy use of these
agents is associated with several
different toxicities
that can be very severe and can be
perhaps fatal in some patients on the
right hand side of this slide you'll see
the breakdown of the pharmacology of
this agent with five fluorouracil in the
middle
five florida uracil goes down one
metabolic pathway to fdump
which is responsible for the efficacy of
this drug
an alternative pathway they can go down
is seen here in red so about
approximately eighty percent of
systemic five a few goes down this
metabolic pathway
where is metabolized to an inactive form
by hydropyrimidine dehydrogenase
this enzyme is encoded by the dpyd gene
over many years of research we have
found that there are recurrent
polymorphisms
of dpyd that reduce the activity of
vpd enzyme here i have listed five of
the
recurrent polymorphisms that have been
highly validated to reduce effectivity
you can see i have highlighted here in
red some of the common names although
there are many different
aliases that we use to describe these
different polymorphisms
each of these polymorphisms is found at
relatively low allele frequency
as you can see all the way on the right
hand side however the combined carrier
frequency is approximately six percent
in caucasians
and about one in three hundred patients
are homozygous for these variants
there are of course many other rare or
singleton
variants that have been reported to be
low or diminished activity
but these five are the main that have
been validated and are
found in many patients
this next slide just shows a little bit
of the consequences of these low
activity d2id polymorphisms
on the left hand side you can see a
figure showing the
the decrease in dpd metabolic activity
in an ex vivo screen in the top row
you'll see that
in 121 samples from non-carriers
their dpd activity range from ranged
from
a median of a little over 200.
below that you'll see the activity in 13
carriers of the star 2a
and in two carriers of the star 13 that
have much lower dpd activity
on the right hand side you'll see a
comparison of the
systemic five flower uracil exposure in
a single index patient who's a star to a
carrier
that's indicated by the diamonds
and that is in comparison in comparison
to six
control patients who are shown
in the triangle you can see the one
patient with the diamonds has much
higher
five a few concentrations and much
prolonged concentrations
relative to the control patients showing
that
carriers of this star 2a polymorphism or
other low activity polymorphisms
have increased systemic exposure to
5-fluorouracil
that increase in systemic exposure is
not now known to be affiliated with an
increase in severe toxicity
there have been many studies and i'll
show you some of those on the next slide
but this is
one of the largest and best studies this
is a retrospective
analysis conducted in a prospective
clinical trial called
ncctgn147
this trial had almost 3 000 patients
with colon cancer
who received standard combination
chemotherapy including 5-fluorouracil
these patients were genotyped for dpyd
star2a
and d949v two of the well-established
low activity polymorphisms
the primary outcome in this analysis was
severe
grade three plus five fluorouracil
related toxicity or adverse events
you can see on the bottom left the
results for the dpyd star 2a carriers
who had a near 90 risk of severe
toxicity
compared with about 30 percent in
non-carriers for an odds ratio or 15.
below that are the results for the
d-949v carriers
showing again about an 80 risk of severe
toxicity
versus about 30 in the non-carriers with
an odds ratio of
approximately nine you can see on the
right-hand side these results were
consistent across
all major subgroups and these results
are consistent with what has been seen
in several other cohorts
here's a study that just showed a
meta-analysis for
five excuse me four of the major
validated variants
so you can see in the upper left hand
corner the dpid star 2a
then going around clockwise the star 13
happy 3 and d9 for 9v
in each case these variants were
associated with a statistically
significant increase in severe toxicity
with adjusted
relative risks between an increase of
about sixty percent for happy three
to a four fold or higher increase for
star 13.
of course those have relatively wide
confidence intervals because of the
small numbers of patients each of these
analyses had at least 4 000 patients in
them
or highly statistically significant
in addition to the increase in severe
toxicity we
also know there's an increase in fatal
toxicity in carriers of dpyd variants
so i have here several reports in
major medical journals of case reports
of individual patients who passed away
of treatment or later found out to be
carriers of a dpyd polymorphism
these have been somewhat repeatedly
reported unfortunately
and there are some well-known stories
and websites that are dedicated to
patient stories
who were treated with standard dose of
fluoropyrimidines
and passed away or had severe toxicity
before finding out they were dpid
carriers
a recent analysis indicates that the
risk of fatal toxicity
in a d2id variant carrier is
approximately three percent
when given standard fluoroprimine dosing
in addition to all these retrospective
reports and retrospective analyses
there are now prospective clinical
studies that demonstrate the benefit
of pre-emptive or pre-treatment dpyd
testing
this is a prospective single-arm trial
of greater than 1 600 patients
who were pre-treatment tested for dpyd
star 2a
based on their star 2a genotype they
received either standard dose
fluoropyrimidine
if they were an impure 50
dose reduction if they carried one copy
or an 85
dose reduction if they carried two
copies of the star 2a variant
they were then dose escalated in future
cycles of treatment
as tolerated which is consistent with
the dose and guidelines
these patients who were pre-treatment
genotypes for
2a were compared with a historical
control
of dpyd star 2a carriers who were not
genotyped prior to treatment
and received its standard dosing this
comparison
is was made to demonstrate the benefits
of pre-treatment testing
there is also a comparison of the star
2a patients who received the just dosing
versus the wild type patients who
received standard dosing so we could see
some of the potential risks of dose
adjustment
and finally there is an analysis of
healthcare costs and i'll show you the
results of these
studies in the next slide
so in the primary analysis looking at
the star 2a carriers who received
adjusted dosing
compared with a historical control of
star 2a carriers
who received standard dosing there was a
significant reduction of grade 3 plus
toxicity
from about 73 in the historical control
to about 30 percent in the dose just
group
with a p-value of less than 0.001
that shows you the benefit of dose
adjustment in star 2a carriers
there is additionally a nominal
reduction in toxicity-related death
from a 10 estimate to 0 although this
did not reach statistical significance
due to the low number of events
again there are also some secondary
analyses to look at the risks of dose
adjustment
specifically the braid three plus
toxicity in our star2a carriers who
received adjust dosing
was compared with our grade three plus
toxicity in
our non-carriers who are wild-type
patients who received standard dosing
and you can see a normalization of
toxicity of about
25 in each group there is also a
normalization of drug concentrations
indicating that these patients the star
2a carriers who receive adjusted dosing
should have normalized efficacy as well
although that was an analysis done
in this publication
finally in their economic analysis
they estimated that dpyd screening prior
to treatment saves
about 60 dollars per patient
this data and other similar data from
other studies
has led to a publication by the clinical
pharmacogenetics implementation
consortium or cpec
describing their recommended dosing for
patients who carry dpyd
who have known dpid genotype so in the
top row here you see your normal
metabolizers that's two patients who
have
excuse me a patient who has two normal
alleles who has normal dpd activity
and should use the label recommended
dosing in administration
in the next row this is a simplified
version indicating that a patient
who carries one no function allele has
decreased tpd activity
and should receive a dose reduction of
about 50
followed by escalation as tolerated
finally in the bottom row our poor
metabolizers who have
no functional alleles have complete tpd
deficiency
they should either avoid use of
fluoropyrimidines or empirically reduce
the starting dose by about 90 percent
again followed by escalation as
tolerated and you can see the full cpic
dosing recommendations at the cpicker
pharm gkb website
so now i'll just quickly go over what
the general benefits and harms of
pre-treatment testing are
so everyone understands the benefits and
risks
of this strategy so again
starting with the benefits of dose
reduction in our
variant carriers which is about six
percent of patients
there is a reduction in grade three plus
toxicity from about
50 to 70 percent to about thirty percent
and a reduction in risk of death from
about three percent
to less than one percent we believe
there's an even greater decrease in the
homozygous patients
however precise estimates are currently
unavailable
of course the benefits of dose reduction
must be considered against the possible
harms or risk to
dose reduction the first potential harm
is the potential for decreased efficacy
particularly in the approximately 30
percent
of dpyd carriers who do not experience
severe toxicity
and were unnecessarily dose adjusted we
believe that there is a low concern for
diminished efficacy
for several reasons the first is there
are reports as i presented earlier
that the drug concentrations and
toxicity are normalized
in the dpyd variant carriers who receive
dose adjustment
in addition as i mentioned in the cpic
guidelines the
dosing guidelines recommend a dose
escalation to tolerability after cycle
one
so all patients should receive their
maximum tolerated dosing as
usual with chemotherapy
a second potential harm that is
sometimes sometimes discussed
is this so-called false sense of
security
there are about thirty percent of
patients who are non-carriers of dpyd
dpid variants who still experience
severe toxicity from standard
fluoropremium dosing
we believe that there is a low concern
for harm or
in fact no harm done to these patients
by genotyping
if you genotype these patients and there
is no genetic variant found
this does not change their dosing or
their monitoring in any way
whether or not this patient received
genotyping they still would receive
their standard fluorophamine dosing they
would still experience the severe
toxicity unfortunately
finally there's some concern for the
overall cost of genotyping
particularly because of the somewhat low
incidence of dpyd variant carrying
as i showed before there is some
evidence that pre-treatment cpid testing
actually saves money per patient in the
range about fifty dollars per patient
this is due to the high treatment costs
in dpyd carriers
who receive fluoropyrimidine dosing
which has been estimated to be
greater than two thousand dollars per
patient due to high risk of toxicity and
hospitalization
also note that there is a somewhat
recently approved antidote
for fluoroprimidine overdosing which is
called uridine trias tape
that treatment costs about eighty
thousand dollars per treatment so you
can see that even preventing
a single case of having to use that drug
makes this very financially viable
when we think about the evidence
supporting pre-treatment testing
we think about what is the evidence of
clinical utility
so clinical utility is defined as the
use of genetics to guide patient care
improves treatment outcomes
i believe that i have presented the
evidence showing that treatment outcomes
are improved in our dpyd variant
carriers
based on pre-treatment genotyping
there are two ways to demonstrate
clinical utility based on a report from
the institute of medicine
the first is a retrospective analysis of
a prospective clinical trial using
archived specimens
and i showed you that in this study from
the ncctg
the second way is a prospective clinical
trial in which the genetic test
directs patient management and i showed
you that in the prospective genotyping
study
the genotype dpyd star 2a and
demonstrated a reduction
in severe toxicity
therefore i think that we have met the
threshold of demonstrating clinical
utility
in both ways that are available and we
have clearly demonstrated
the clinical benefit of pre-treatment
dpid testing in patients who are going
to receive fluoropyrimidine treatment
many groups have agreed that we have
surpassed the threshold of clinical
utility and testing is now recommended
throughout europe
testing for dpyd or dpd activity is
required in france in the netherlands
and over the course of 2020 has been
recommended by
many of the medical agencies in europe
including the european medicines agency
however in the united states testing is
not recommended by any major body
including the fda asco or the nccn
and currently although we believe the
frequency is unknown
excuse me although we believe that
testing is uncommon the frequency of
testing in the united states is unknown
we did an internal survey at the
university of michigan of our medical
oncologists
to understand their practices and
beliefs about dpid or dpd testing
we asked this survey to 16 medical
oncologists who use fluoropyrimidine
who mostly came from breast or gi
oncology
here's a histogram of the number of
patients who
these medical oncologists started on a
new chemotherapy regimen
that contained afluropyrimidine so you
can see that many of our oncologists use
these
agents in about one patient per month
where some of our medical oncologists
use these agents in
10 or more patients per month
our first question was have our medical
oncologist
ever ordered a dpyd or dpd test prior to
starting fluoropremium chemotherapy
you can see that about 80 of our medical
oncologists had never ordered a test
prior to treatment
whereas about 20 percent had we then
asked of those
medical oncologists who have ordered
testing
how often they order testing and why two
of the oncologists two out of the three
who said they had ordered testing said
that they rarely do
one medical oncologist said that for
selected patients they order testing
based on performance status
we then ask several questions about
their beliefs about dpid genotype
and the pre-treatment testing the first
question
shown here in red on the right-hand side
is do you agree with the statement that
dpd deficiency increases toxicity risk
in patients through the fluoroprimitins
as you can see most of our clinicians
strongly agree with this statement
however the next question shown in the
purple was do you agree with the
statement that
testing of dpd or dpyd is useful to
inform treatment
and here you can see a much more normal
distribution
with most medical oncologists in the
middle saying they neither
neither agree nor disagree with that
statement only about a quarter
of medical oncologists agreeing with the
statement that pre-treatment testing is
useful
we then asked for about several factors
that we believed
might prevent medical oncologists from
ordering testing and i'll go through
some of the major highlights
so the factor that was endorsed to be
extremely or very important by most
medical oncologists was the lack of
clinical guidelines
from any of the major guideline
committees as i mentioned earlier
the next most common response was the
low prevalence of dpd deficiency
followed by the potential concern for
decreased efficacy from dose reduction
there were several other factors asked
about that had much lower concern
including testing cost
and a concern that dpd
testing will not reduce treatment
toxicity
one final question we asked about was
whether gpd deficiency is actionable
information
so here we asked if you knew that your
patient was dpd deficient
what would you do with that information
you can say that none of our medical
oncologists said that they would not do
anything
every medical oncologist said this would
be actionable information
with most saying they would decrease
fluoroprimine dosing
or some saying that they would consult a
clinical
guideline to find out what to do with
dosing or switch to a non-fluoroprimine
treatment
so you can see that when this
information is known it should
definitely be used because it's
actionable to guide treatment
so in conclusion our survey confirms
that
dpd deficiency is
known and understood to increase
toxicity risk
however few individuals or few medical
oncologists are
ordering dpd testing mostly because the
lack of clinical guidelines
this survey has been approved for
national distribution through swag and
we hope to have results in the near
future
now that we have uh demonstrated that
there is an
improvement in clinical care from
pre-treatment testing
i'll show you some of the work that
we're doing to increase the amount of
pre-treatment testing that's being done
the current status is that few
fluoropromine treated patients
are tested prior to treatment there are
some sites and clinicians who i'm aware
of
that are ordering testing and there's
some advocate efforts to increase
the patient awareness to ask for testing
one of the things that we've done at the
university of michigan local cancer
center
is to use our existing dpyd data to make
sure that patients who have
known dpd deficiency are being treated
accordingly
so we have a large program called the
michigan genomics initiative that has
it's a genetic data repository from
greater than 60 000 patients
who have genome-wide genotyping
information this information cannot be
used for clinical decision making
however it can be used for
clinical research what we have done is
we've set up a clinical research study
that is essentially an implementation
project
where we have found we have received the
names
of the approximately three thousand
patients who are known carriers of one
of the five dpyd variants
based on this mgi data we've set up
automated alerts in our medical record
so anytime one of these dpyd carriers is
diagnosed
with a fluoropyrimidine treated tumor
our study team gets notified
we then contact the medical oncologist
to confirm this patient is going to
receive a floral primitive
and enroll the patient on our study and
order and pay for their confirmatory
dpid testing through the mayo clinic
upon confirming their dpid status we
return this information to the medical
oncologist
within the electronic medical record and
provide them a dosing recommendation
so that this patient can receive safe
and effective dosing
we launched this study in september of
2020 and
launched our automated alert system
we immediately found that there was a
dpyd carrier
in the mgi data who had previously
that week been newly diagnosed with
colon cancer
we immediately contacted medical
oncologist and confirmed that this
patient is expected to receive
combination chemotherapy including a
five-floor uracil
we then enrolled the subject the
following day and sent their dpid test
and returned that information with the
confirmed dpyd happy3 carrier status to
medical oncologist
within seven days of launching our alert
demonstrating
the efficiency and rapidity of getting
this information for patients
in terms of the efficiency it cost us
six hundred dollars to
identify and confirm one dpyd variant
carrier
compared with about twelve thousand
dollars per dpyd variant carrier
uh identified in doing pre-treatment
screening of all patients
we plan to expand this process to
ugtp1a1 and other genes
that are actionable in patients with
cancer
a much larger pool of patients could be
could benefit if we added dpid
to somatic and germline cancer genetic
testing panels
this is a concept that i published on
last year in the journal of the national
comprehensive cancer network
so in terms of germline cancer panels we
know that many cancer patients undergo
multi-gene germline testing to find
cancer predisposition
according to the nccn guidelines all
patients with pancreatic cancer and many
patients with
colorectal breast and ovarian cancer
should receive some kind of germline
testing
these are all tumors that are commonly
treated with the fluoroprimine treatment
the nccn guidelines recommend multi-gene
testing
and specify that not all genes included
on the panels are necessarily actionable
i would argue that dpy are actionable
and should be included on these panels
there are some germline panels that do
include dpid
including the panel from color genomics
however others do not
including panels for germline genetic
testing by
ambry and nvite we are very interested
in working with these companies
to add dpyd to their existing panels
similarly there are many patients with
cancer that undergo somatic
or tumor genetic testing to select a
targeted treatment
we believe that by adding dpyd to these
cancer genetic panels we could
achieve the benefits of dpid testing for
limited additional cost
there are some tumor genetic panels
including that from tempus
which also include germline testing and
have included dpyd
however however other commonly used
panels such as that from foundation 1
are only tumor testing and do not
include dpyd
we are currently working with a
foundation group to try to
work with some of these companies to try
to convince them to add dpyd
so patients can benefit from this
information
finally we really hope to get to the
point where all fluoroprominene treated
patients
are genotyped for gpyd prior to
treatment
in order to do so again based on what we
heard from medical oncologists
we need to get the guidelines panels on
board with recommending fluoropyrimidine
uh excuse me dpyd testing in patients
who are going to receive a
fluoropyrimidine
specifically we are interested in
getting recommendations from the nccn
and or the fda
the nccn treatment guidelines for colon
cancer
currently include the following
the following quotes so the colon cancer
guidelines state that individuals with
variants of dpid have a significantly
elevated risk for severe
life-threatening toxicity
acknowledging the clinical validity or
the increase in risk in these carriers
they go on to say that pre-treatment
dpid testing showed a significant
reduction
in the risk of grade 3 toxicity
acknowledging the clinical utility of
pre-treatment testing
they then concluded by saying that
universal pre-treatment testing
remains controversial and the mccm panel
does not support it at this time
despite acknowledging the clinical
validity in clinical utility
we submitted a request in 2019 outlining
some of the more recent data
recommending that germline dpid testing
be added to the routine pre-treatment
workup for all patients
likely to receive a flow of pyrimidine
followed by dosing according to the cpic
as i uh presented earlier
their response was the panel did not
support the inclusion of dpyd testing as
a routine component of
the pre-treatment workup and the final
vote was unanimous of 0-22
they did not give us any reasoning for
this
however what we understand is that the
nccm guidelines are based on current
clinical practice
so here we have a classic chicken
situation
so the clinician practice is not to
order testing
and they say this is because of a lack
of clinical guidelines from the mccn
then ccn does not update their
guidelines to include
testing because their guidelines reflect
what happens in clinical practice
and here neither group is ready to make
this first step because they're waiting
for the other
to lead the way
we hope that one day to break this log
jam excuse me one way to break this log
jam
is to get a recommendation from the fda
for pre-treatment dpyd screening
so the fda package inserts for 530
uracil and cape cytobean
were updated in 2016 to acknowledge that
patients
with certain mutations in dpid are at
increased risk for
severe early onset toxicity that can be
fatal and that patients with partial dpd
activity may also have increased risk
which i showed you from
earlier studies in the patient
counseling
information of the package insert it
advises that patients should notify
their healthcare provider
if they have known dpd deficiency the
issue is that patients would not know
this
prior to receiving the flurry of
pyrimidine we have submitted
a fda citizen petition with mr ken
cerpenette a well-known patient advocate
for
d2id testing and several other leaders
in this field
we recommended adding a black black box
warning
for the toxicity risk and to recommend
pre-treatment dpd screening
in patients in patients who are going to
receive fluoroprimitin
we also requested that they recommend
dpd-guided dosing
from cpic or other such dosing
guidelines
there's a qr code that you can scan with
your phone
so you can read our petition and there
is currently an open comment period so
you can add supportive
or not supportive comments to the fda
changing the package insert to recommend
pre-treatment testing
thank you much for thank you very much
for attending
my presentation here's that qr code if
you'd like to comment on our fda
petition
we really would appreciate your support
and i look forward to
answering any questions from the
audience thank you very much